et sachez que la libye au robot ses
frontières avec la tunisie après deux
mois de fermeture regard de la situation
sanitaire catastrophique qu'a connu la
tunisie cet été les autorités libyennes
ont décidé de suspendre les déplacements
les échanges commerciaux avec leurs
voisins une situation qui n'a fait que
fragiliser davantage l'économie
tunisienne déjà durement frappée par la
crise économique et politique précision
depuis tunis de notre correspondant
bassem chips c'est une annonce aux
allures de bouffée d air frais pour
l'économie tunisienne est celle de la
réouverture des frontières avec le
voisin libyen prévu dès aujourd'hui elle
fait suite à la réunion de mercredi
dernier entre délégations sanitaires et
sécuritaires tunisienne et libyenne qui
s'était tenue sur l'île de djerba mais
carthage a prévenu que cette réouverture
sera scruté de très près objectif éviter
une recrudescence des nouveaux cas de
coronavirus le président de la
république aït-saïd a annoncé
l'organisation d'une campagne de
vaccination spécifique au niveau des
postes frontaliers en collaboration avec
les autorités libyennes écouté il est
nécessaire de respecter pleinement le
protocole sanitaire qui pourrait être
révisée au regard de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire dans les deux pays
tout manquement à ces exigences
pourraient entraîner un réexamen de la
décision de rouvrir les postes
frontaliers le 8 juillet dernier est la
libye avait décidé de fermer ses
frontières avec la tunisie et de
suspendre toutes les liaisons aériennes
en raison d'une quatrième vague
particulièrement meurtrière chez son
voisin peu de temps après tunis décidé
d'en faire de même paralysant une partie
de l'économie nationale premier
partenaire économique des tunisiens dans
le continent tripoli a toujours
représenté une source de revenus
importante pour de nombreux commerçants
et entreprises avant la pandémie les
échanges commerciaux entre les deux pays
représentaient pas moins d'un milliard
250 millions de dollars par an selon le
conseil économique et social contre 300
millions annuels depuis le début de la
crise du coronavirus un manque à gagner
conséquent pour le pays durement touché
par une triple crise économique
politique et sanitaire grâce à la
solidarité internationale la tunisie a
bénéficié 2000 on de doses antico vide
ce qui a permis d'accélérer sa campagne
de vaccination à ce jour plus de 26 % de
la population a complété son schéma
vaccinal les autorités tunisiennes
espère atteindre 50% de vacciner d'ici
le mot décembre